Olá você já se perguntou o que
aconteceria se adicionasse orégano aos
seus pratos todos os dias ou se você
tomasse chá de orégano regularmente o
orégano não é apenas um toque de sabor
ele pode ser um grande aliado na luta
contra diversas doenças desde melhorar a
digestão a circulação até combater
fungos e bactérias o orégano tem muito a
oferecer pessoal hoje eu vou te mostrar
como aproveitar máximas propriedades do
orégano utilizando métodos caseiros como
a preparação de um chá ou a criação de
um óleo de orégano feito com azeite de
oliva ou óleo de coco mas por que estou
tão entusiasmado com orégano na
realidade ele é parte da minha indicação
para meus pacientes onde vejo resultados
muito bons permitam-me compartilhar uma
história de um dos meus pacientes ele
chegou ao meu consultório com sintomas
digestórios preocupantes com gastrite
uma infecção por H pilor licob bacter
pilor uma bactéria que está presente no
estômago de algumas pessoas e pode
causar processos inflamatórios como
gastrites úlceras e até câncer bom
apesar dos tratamentos convencionais
trazerem alívio temporário os sintomas e
a infecção persistiam nesse paciente Foi
então que sugerir uma abordagem
diferente a inclusão do chá de orégano
em sua rotina diária isso após
tratamento completo direcionado a
combater a infecção com o tempo ele
observou uma melhora bem sustentável e
significativa em sua condição a
manutenção com chá de orégano combinado
a mudanças na dieta trouxe uma nova
esperança e bem-estar ao longo prazo
para ele então pessoal a primeira coisa
que eu quero destacar e falar sobre o
orégano é que ele pode ajudar na luta
contra bactérias e fungos e Isso é uma
grande vantagem mas tem algo importante
que você precisa saber o orégano Não age
tão rapidamente quanto o remédio
farmácia quando usamos orégano seja na
forma de chá ou óleo Ele trabalha mais
devagar mas de forma segura sem causar
aqueles efeitos chatos ou prejudiciais
que alguns remédios Podem trazer porém
lembre-se em caso de urgência como
infecções agudas Fora de Controle você
deve seguir o que seu médico receitou o
orégano tem dois componentes poderosos o
carvacrol e o timol esses dois
ingredientes têm propriedades
antibacterianas antifungicas antivirais
isso torna especialmente o óleo de
orégano capaz de lidar com 23 tipos
diferentes de bactérias nocivas Além
disso é eficaz contra fungos como a
cândida albicans é útil para varas e
condições intestinais um aspecto
positivo do do orégano é que ele é
seletivo na sua ação enquanto combate
microrganismos prejudiciais ele mantém
uma boa relação com as bactérias
benéficas do nosso intestino isso é
essencial para manter o equilíbrio
saudável do sistema digestório o óleo de
orégano pode ser particularmente útil em
casos como excesso de bactérias no
intestino delgado cibo infecção por
helicobacter pilórico como eu já
mencionei infecções fúngicas do
intestino chamado de cifo além isso ele
mostra eficácia contra vírus de herps
alguns vírus que causam diarreia e
também tem ação contra vários parasitas
que afeta o sistema digestório além de
ser um grande aliado no combate a
microorganismos o orégano tem outros
benefícios incríveis pra saúde que vão
surpreender você ele é um tesouro de
nutrientes repleto de vitamina A C E e k
além de ser fonte de fibras folatos
Ferro magnésio vitamina B6 cálcio e
potássio ele se destaca pelo seu alto
teor de antioxidantes especialmente o
ácido rosmarínico que possui um poder
antioxidante 42 vezes maior que da maçã
uma coisa que pouca gente sabe é que o
orégano também é uma fonte interessante
de ácidos grácos
ômega-3 esse tipo de gordura que é
benéfico para coração evita entupimento
das artérias além de ser
antiinflamatório e ajudar muito na saúde
do cérebro pessoal o chá de orégano pode
contribuir para afinar o sangue e
prevenir a formação de coágulos seus
compostos bioativos T propriedades
anticoagulantes antiinflamatórias que
podem ajudar a manter as veias livres de
obstruções eficiente pra saúde do fígado
ele ajuda na eliminação de toxinas e
melhora a função hepática Além disso
alivia sintomas de distúrbios urinários
nas mulheres o uso regular de orégano
pode regular ular a menstruação evitar
cólicas pra saúde cardiovascular o
orégano ajuda a equilibrar o colesterol
e previne doenças cardíacas além de
regular a pressão arterial com o seu
potássio o orégano também pode ser
utilizado para tratamento de infecções
urinárias por várias bactérias como
Proteus klebsiela esquicha cole Além
disso um composto chamado carnosol
presente no orégano apresentou
propriedades anticancerígenas para
tumores de próstata tumores de mama
intestino grosso e também de pele além
do Câncer sanguíneo a leucemia pessoal
além dos benefícios já mencionados o
orégano tem um papel especial no alívio
da tosse isso se deve a suas
propriedades antiinflamatórias similares
a do gengibre e do mel imagine preparar
um chá de orégano com um pouquinho de
gengibre e mel esse chá pode ser um
remédio caseiro perfeito para crise de
tosse especialmente útil durante gripes
e resfriados o carvacrol um dos
componentes do orégano que eu já discuti
tem a capacidade de suprimir substâncias
pró-inflamatórias reduzindo a inflamação
nas vias aéreas e aliviando a
hiperatividade brônquica o que pode ser
particularmente benéfico para pessoas
com asma ou bronquite crônica a nossa
comunidade de membros que tira dúvidas
comigo diretamente em lives semanais
exclusivas já aprendeu muito sobre saúde
conheça esse e outros benefícios clique
no botão abaixo e seja membro pessoal
plantar orégano em casa é uma excelente
ideia ele cresce bem em vasos e pode ser
uma adição prática e bonita a sua
cozinha usar folhas frescas de orégano
nos alimentos não só traz frescor aos
pratos mas também garante que você
esteja aproveitando ao máximo as
propriedades da erva claro que o orégano
seco que você acha facilmente em
mercados também uma ótima opção e quanto
ao chá de orégano para preparar o chá
com orégano desidratado ferva uma xícara
de água e após ferver Desligue o fogo
adicione uma colher de sopa Rasa de
orégano deixe repousar por 5 a 10
minutos coe e beba se estiver usando
orégano fresco use duas colheres de sopa
da erva e siga o mesmo processo você
sabia que pode fazer um óleo de orégano
usando apenas azeite de oliva ou óleo de
coco esse método preserva todas as
qualidades benéficas do orégano e é
surpreendentemente fácil primeiro lave e
seque bem as folhas de orégano coloque
as folhas em um local seco e arejado
para que sequem completamente em seguida
pique-os e encha a metade de um frasco
de vidro com as folhas secas depois
despeje o óleo escolhido até cobrir
completamente as folhas de orégano agite
o frasco suavemente para garantir que
não haja as bolhas de ar e que as bolhas
estejam completamente submersas no óleo
agora vem um passo importante coloque o
frasco em um local escuro que seja mais
quente em sua casa mas lembre-se de
evitar a exposição direta à luz solar
uma dica é colocar o frasco dentro de um
saco de papel o que ajuda a deixar o
ambiente mais quente e proteger a
mistura dos raios solares guarde o
frasco nesse local por no mínimo 30 dias
agitando de vez em quando após esse
período de maceração coi o óleo através
de uma gaze para separar as folhas do
Óleo transfira o óleo para outro frasco
de vidro higienizado Feche o bem e
guarde em um local fresco e seco esse
precioso óleo de orégano caseiro pode
durar até um ano e você pode usar nas
suas Preparações de receitas diárias Se
você precisar de mais potência no
tratamento recomendo a compra de óleo de
orégano comercial de boa procedência ou
extrato seco principalmente pela
segurança e precisão na dosagem esses
produtos são desenvolvidos para garantir
que você receba a quantidade certa de
ingredientes ativos ao optar por
cápsulas de extrato de orégano
manipulado ou comercial a dosagem típica
é de cerca de 250 mg tomada de uma a
duas vezes ao dia de de maneira
preferencial durante as refeições por 10
dias pessoal é importante que seja feito
com Orientação médica já o óleo
essencial de orégano que é super
concentrado é versátil e pode ser
utilizado de maneira tópica na pele mas
sempre diluído no óleo carreador como
óleo de coco de amêndoas para evitar
irritações misture uma a duas gotas do
óleo essencial para uma colher de sopa
do óleo carreador é útil para massagem
em áreas de tensão muscular ou
articulações doloridas tratamento de
problemas de pele como acne e alívio de
picadas em insetos uma aplicação
interessante é o tratamento de micose
das Unhas onde pode ser aplicado
diretamente desde que diluído eu vou
deixar um vídeo na descrição de como
usar o óleo essencial de orégano na
micose de unha quanto a ingestão é
crucial que o óleo de orégano seja de
alta qualidade indicado para consumo
pelo fabricante a dose recomendada é de
cerca de duas a quatro gotas por dia
sempre diluídas em um veículo comestível
como óleo de coco azeite e de
preferência misturado em alimentos nunca
deve ser ingerido puro Antes de iniciar
o uso É aconselhável fazer um teste de
alergia na pele e consultar um
profissional de saúde especialmente em
caso de gravidez lactação ou se estiver
tomando medicamentos continue comigo
assiste esses dois vídeos relacionad que
são muito interessantes São Sensacionais
todo mundo deveria conhecer esses
sintomas desconhecidos de vermes e
parasitas e o outro vídeo é 15 sinais na
pele que revelam problemas do fígado
eles estão aparecendo aí na sua tela
Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
Você é
fera